yacht au monde c'est squeeze aujourd'hui
on se retrouve sur un nouveau jeu
d'horreur non parce länder la version
bêta ont la main un petit peu de côté on
attend que le jeu final sort pour
s'éclater dessus avec les petites filles
tous qui seront ajoutés brèche vous
raconterez 200 une prochaine vidéo
là c'est un peu un dérivé de style
enders ma foi j'ai juste l'envié de la
dernière fois sans même bouger donc je
regarde la mouffe caractère action mouse
shift juan fc pour aller matin le maire
et prendre les papiers c'est eux
ok donc en gros pareil il faut prendre 8
papers a donc j'avais juste pas avant sa
dernière fois je vais augmenter un peu
le son à mon dieu c'est incroyable un
homme qui marche comme ça fait des pas
assez les genres hoba hoba hoba ultra
vite je veux bien la langue par qu'on se
plaît se plaît non je sais pas ok
d'accord c'est cool c'est super d'accord
pas de soucis entre il est bien l es12 y
avait une porte dans ce pack ou leurs
secrets non c'est un piège moi car on
calme le jeu d'entrée de jeu plutôt
merde ça mais ce répit cet effet alors
si vous êtes du genre à avoir mal à tête
facilement dans l'herbe et surtout quand
tu cours va je dirais qu'il a un marteau
piqueur dans le cucquois le gall qui
courent bon allez on continue on peut
lire ce qu'on peut à l'aide d'un meuble
on peut en train de maison il n'y a rien
dans la maison
seulement génial merde quoi les [ __ ]
toi c'est quoi ça c'est quoi ce petit
hôpital à guînes support to bordel de
merde mégane iii mais dès qu'un jeu
[ __ ] réservé à une merveille ses
partenaires mais c'est ta mais attends
là c'est pas les petits de scanner sébum
dès que tu te retournes quoi [ __ ] de
merde mais je vais n'importe où la
[ __ ] va ce père va pas trop et ses
plus bas de page
non mais c'est bon tu me fait plus peur
gros tas mais le mec il est sérieux mais
c'est pas possible quoi c'est lui là bas
vers la bombe
regardez regardez regardez le ah non pas
à la mode en ces pages
non c'est une page nickel j'en ai une
super au plus elles sont trop bas tabara
c'est le slender low budget ça s'appelle
[ __ ] de merde bordel la vache
[ __ ] on est perdu au milieu et pas que
c'est super à la mode en ce moment de
retrouver dans une forêt à 3h du mat 1
hrc huit pages c'est pas pourquoi
peut-être cours de match qu'il a perdu
en avion mais bon ça mais bordel mais
sur vos tombes merde tu en mets ton
coeur ils sont là mais c'est horrible
sayah jugé shoah là j'ai envie de me
mettre tout nu la jupe crève de chaud
non mais c'est quoi ces arbres au le
stand up all eyes on va très mal nul 1-1
peu pixelisé tout de même je dirais tu
as mais je sais pas où je vais je
comprends rien je bordel de merde je
fais pas lieu n'empêche que cette terre
mais bizarre ce petit bonhomme là bas
encore plus aux [ __ ] tas il est super
glauque le mec par contre aux [ __ ]
concours concours concours court en plus
j'ai de la vie c'est dire qu'ils peuvent
attaquer ou comment ça se passe quels
sont les buy
ok j'ai une batterie sur la lampe
possible génial bon c'est génial bon je
prouve que je propose de recommencer
correctement qu'on puisse on ne peut pas
très bien je pense que je relis gens
alors espérons que cette fois on
retrouve un peu plus notre chemin
j'aimerais bien apprendre la langue je
ne peux pas c'est mon choix je les prix
assez bon c'est bon c'est bon on a pas
que tu les obtiens outils dont j'avais
pas fait ça tout à del nido ya une porte
qui nouvelle à outils 2 au phoque
ils ont fait le jeu des chaises volantes
énorme
[ __ ] serait descendu les adhérents du
maïdo made ok on se casse non mais ces
prix à rien en fait [ __ ] de merde
commencer y'a pas le petit [ __ ] de
bonhomme ici là non y'a personne on se
casse
car entre les gens bon alors ce qui n'a
pas une page ici à elle vous êtes des
flics bolton one on va partir au combat
du combattant va découvrir que son
véhicule soit je te regarde bien quoi tu
vois un coup de tête
tu vois un coup de tête mon frère tu as
quoi là à bâtard ça fait peur quand j'ai
de merde
bon alors pour la langue j'aimerais bien
trouver au moins à une autre page a
éventuellement moynier donc d'accord les
voitures du futur
c'était pas des pneus c'est déboulent
les syllabes d'accord super incroyable
bon allez c'est parti
dab et avoir des [ __ ] d'endroits
comme en fait ok c'est une maison hantée
les finitions les flics sont venus ils
ont une histoire d'ego mais et toi tu
charges est rodé des pages sur des armes
et ne pas juste là d'ailleurs en passant
voilà je m'en bats les couilles soit une
page enjoy jan balik c'est bon il ya
toujours pas le petit bonhomme blanc
dans un bus en fait c'était servant un
truc de fou ces mêmes principes que les
escrimeurs toute la vidéo et max de son
superbe à dk'bus traver il va être super
fort du coup tu vas tu augmentes tension
c'est lui que le son est battu voix pour
que tu entendes un peu et la base
desquels escrimeurs sap t'éclate lagord
pas exactement comme ça [ __ ] super
attendait non mais c'est un vote le mec
n'a pas fait dans droits spécifiques
pour trouver non et a fait une forêt
mais nous sommes un peu partout de vue
n'importe où sans balai kuwait cm qui
trouve lui même ou à la peau tu auras la
[ __ ] c'est abusé quoi s'il te plaît
j'aimerais bien éventuellement trouver
une seconde page si possible cette
lettre est moins chère 360 creamer s'est
totalement super génial bon écoutez le
seul énorme budget d'un jeu totalement
nul à chier je propose de quitter en
allant voir le bonhomme qui est juste là
tu vois un coup de tête cambodge punk
pop punk